uh Tuesday 12 o'clock at uh the 18th of
November and yeah I'm excited to uh
welcome you to this special presentation
on the order's verticality indicator for
uh Ninja Trader 8 and you know this is
something that uh has been in the works
for a while and you know the whole point
of it was you know you often you look at
these charts and you see you know sharp
moves moves up, sharp moves down, and
you wish, you know, you're always asking
yourself, well, what is the one thing?
Um, was there anything that gave it away
in the order flow? And unfortunately,
there's not just generally one thing
that happens over and over before.
There's sort of a a combination of
things. And, you know, we've distilled
it down into the verticality indicator.
Okay. And you know, I'm just going to go
through a couple of slides first and
then uh you know, we'll we'll we'll go
through uh sort of what makes it uh you
know, makes the signals and you know how
to show you guys how to use it. So, you
know, why vertical moves matter when you
think of vertical, you know, it's up and
down, right? And you know, generally the
most profitable moves that you see in
the E- Minis, the NASDAQ, crude oil, and
and other futures are those those
straight up and down moves. Um well I
mean it's not you know exactly perfectly
straight but you know you understand
what I'm saying right like for example
this is uh you know this is ultra bonds
right you got this nice move down sharp
move down pretty much you know the whole
trend down right you're talking from you
know 121 all the way down to basically
120 even um you know in in different
markets you know you see them over and
over and over okay and it's it's just
one of those things. You know, this is
NASDAQ, right? You see the the move um
just recently. This is a 302nd uh chart.
You know, just from 11:35, we're talking
a move from 540
all the way up to, you know, we're we're
at 760 right now. Okay. And you're
starting to see some sell signals come
in. I mean, this is NASDAQ this morning.
Um you know, if you remember, we had
that nice sharp move down, right? And it
looks like right now we've sort of
recovered uh you know most of that move
that we had going down this morning.
We've sort of recovered it just right
here in this move. And and you know as a
trader you know when you're looking at a
chart you you see the market is it's
under pressure all day. You know people
want to be getting short but there's
usually something in the order flow at
at lows. You know you can see you had an
earlier move here from you know
basically the the six the 460 all the
way up into the 650s. This is a 200
point move. A 200 point move here. 200
point move here. You get some smaller
moves here. You know, this doesn't look
like much. This move up from 919, but
it's a move from about 500 almost, you
know, to 600,
right? And and these moves, they happen
very fast. And I always wanted to um
have a way how to use orderflow to to
catch moves like that, right? And you
know, I mean, when moves happen fast, it
it gives you an advantage in in a couple
of ways, right? Because
obviously on a fastmoving market, it
doesn't retrace that much once it starts
running, right? You you've seen these
markets move and just take off um
immediately. Okay? And and why? Well,
it's these surges, right? And don't when
I say surge, don't immediately think of
the Delta surge. It's it's nothing to do
with the Delta surge. Um it's just a
word. that I'm using here are driven by
institutional order flow right you get
big buy sell imbalances absorption um
stop cascades and what do I mean by stop
cascade is um you know people that have
stops at various levels and stops just
seem to be running into each other which
add fuel to the fire and most traders
they only see this after they happen
after you know these events happen and
the moves are already taking place and
your goal as a trader is to anticipate
these vertical moves before they start
and that's how we use order flow, right?
So, what is verticality? Well, it's it's
a tool that detects or reads um
basically nine orderflow signals that
precede vertical price runs, right? And
again, like I said, it encompasses a lot
of things, but not all nine have to
happen at at the same time is a
combination of them. And it's designed
from the ground up for traders who
already use footprint charts, but want
automated objective alerts, right? The
to tell you that, hey, you know what? We
have verticality potentially taking
place here and purpose of it is to let
you trade at the beginning of explosive
moves not after the crowd gets in.
Right? You want to get in as as soon as
possible. Now what does it monitor?
Well, it monitors imbalances, absorption
zones, um you know delta divergences and
you know generally speaking when I talk
about delta divergence with the
footprint um I'm talking at uh highs or
lows of the day. Uh we took it a you
know we stepped it back a little bit. So
it's not just at highs and lows of the
days. Um it's appearing in the bars. Uh
trap traders and stop clusters, right? I
mean trap when traders are get stuck. Um
you know it's often they're they're
stopped out of a pos, you know, trap
traders happen for a number of reasons.
Okay. And when traders are trapped, you
know, they have stops in the market and
those stops, you know, are sort of
clustered around certain areas and they
tend to get wiped out which adds fuel to
the fire. Um there's going to be thin
prints, exhaustion prints. You can see
PC migration and the the purpose of
verticality indicator is when these
signals align at levels in the market.
Now again, it doesn't it's not you got
to have combination of of all these
different things. um
is a few of them working together
because again you know you could have
sometimes you could have an
basically what I'm saying is
you have to have a set of data that
you're looking at okay and you have to
say okay when the these when certain
amounts of these things happen that's a
signal okay it's not when everything
happens when everything happens it's
like getting the planets aligned right
it's going to happen once in a blue moon
but you only really need um certain of
those events happening around the same
time.
Now it goes beyond delta and signal
imbalances that requires confluence for
signals, right? I mean a lot of tools
that I see on the market. You know, I
develop a lot of tools and and I know
what goes into analyzing order flow and
you can't just look at one delta. You
can't just look at one imbalance, right?
Something like that. That that's just
not enough because it could just be a
big order hitting the market. What you
want, right? And think about if a
market's about to go straight up
or parabolic, if you will.
There's there's a combination of things
that need to take place, right?
Generally, you want to see some signs of
absorption at lower levels, right? And
then what do you want to see after that,
right? You want to see strong aggressive
buying coming in, right? And then when
you see that coming in, then you got to
look a little bit deeper. How is volume
being distributed in a bar? Okay, then
you want to look at how volume is
trading in a bar, right? And that's what
verticality does. Don't ask me
specifically how to calculate it because
you know that that's our proprietary
information that that's um you know all
the work that we've done
over the years for this indicator you
know to say hey you know give me the
formula for and I I you know people will
do that they'll ask me that then they'll
get upset oh Michael's not sharing it.
Well, yeah, I've built it into a tool
for you guys to use, and it works across
all futures markets and time frames,
right? As I'm going to show you in in
the chart examples, it's easy to use.
You can uh overlay it directly on your
existing order flow footprint charts or
candlestick charts.
Generally, when I create an indicator, I
I like to create indicators that will
run on um bar charts because, you know,
me, I like to have multiple charts open
at once. Um keep things going so I can
see, you know, if one market is is
quiet, I could easily see what's
happening in another market. Okay.
So, how's it going to help you trade
better? Well, you're not going to be
chasing moves. You're going to be
positioned ahead of breakout runs and
and market collapses. um you're going to
get entries with tight logical stops,
you know, below absorption or stop
zones. Um
profit taking. Okay, I wrote in there,
you know, warns you when vertical
momentum is exhausted. But really what
what you'll be what I mean by that is,
you know, there's going to be, you know,
generally speaking, an opposite signal
come in, right? Like here, you had this
nice run up and then you get the sell
signals come in. Just as here you have
the run up, you get the sell signal.
just on this move down, you get the buy
signals. Okay, that's how you know
clearly a move is over. Um, for stop
placement, obviously we draw a little
line out from the bottom of these areas.
That's going to be your stop area. Okay?
And you see the nice thing about a lot
of these moves
on true moves, there's not a lot of
retracement,
right? just is down here and up here
going up.
That's how you know a market is going
vertical. Okay? And
what verticality indicator helps you do
is it it forces you to trade with
institutional flow instead of against
it. You know, sometimes people send me
charts, say, can you analyze this? What
I do wrong? And I look at it and I see
traders basically trying to fight the
institutional order flow.
That's not a recipe for dinner, right?
You're going to you're you're going to
lose nine times out of 10, right?
Because the institutional order flow is
much bigger than the retail order flow.
And to be honest, you know, we're just
retail traders, we're just bugs on the
on the windshield of um institutional
traders.
So, it's going to also save you time by
reducing overtrading, okay? and and keep
you focused on high quality setups. All
right, so let's take a look here at it.
I mean, I see some questions coming in.
Someone wanted me to show an e- mini
chart. This is E- Minis um this morning
right now. And
you know, here's right. So, you just you
just simply load it as a simple as any
other indicator um that you have, right?
You just find verticality, add it on
here. Um, after you after you get your
license, right, you just enter it in the
license token and you'll see the
settings are are very basic, right? We
we purposely kept it simple because we
don't I don't like seeing traders
overthink things, okay? And traders love
to overthink things. So, if you want to
use multiple time frame, meaning other
than like I got a one minute chart here.
Say I want to use um, you know, a
rangebased chart for the analysis. I
could choose that or a tick base or
volume base. Um or even go down to I got
a minute-based chart. Maybe I want to
look at 30 second um signals generated
from a 30-cond chart on here. That's why
you see here 30 because earlier I was in
the past I was looking at a 30 second
signals on a one minute chart. Um but
then you know if you just want to use
the chart just set it at chart. Doesn't
matter what you have in here. It'll just
give you the signals based on the chart.
Now the settings very easy. verticality
strength, swing filter and swing period,
minimum volume required. You got
momentum strength, PC movement, and
sound alert. Okay. Some of the other
settings, this is the standard uh
visuals, you know, how it appears on the
chart like the uh until tested the zones
being drawn out. um you know how high or
how low the signal is going to come in
above and below the opacity 25%
um
I have it until tested but if you want
to just have it out a fixed level you
just have it at fixed okay and signal
mark displacement um two okay
now you know sometimes you're going to
see like some some bars where you know
it's like the signal name. Where is it?
Here. Get the crosshairs.
Like right here. It's because I have the
trade entry signal turned on, which I'll
get to in a second. Um, but let's just
go through a couple other settings.
Trade entry signals. This one is set to
one and five, meaning um the market has
to move at least one tick in the
direction of the signal within the next
five bars. Normally I use two and two
but you know the
one of the beta testers was telling me
one and five it works well but you could
change it you know if you want to be one
and one meaning it's got to move
immediately
you just change that here mean it would
have to move by one tick or the next one
bar this data series setup visual don't
have to touch any of this and the plots
down here at the bottom is just how it
appears on your chart okay so I got blue
triangle up for buys, red triangle down
for sells. Okay,
now I've conveniently pulled up a bunch
of charts here for you. Um, this is from
actually yesterday and I was going to
talk through some of the settings,
right? Because again, the setting that
matters the most is verticality
strength. Okay. Now, should be noted
verticality uh sorry um momentum
strength
and PC movement are kind of similar.
They're both
um
momentum tools. Okay. Now, we already
have a PC analysis within verticality.
This is just, you know, another step.
You can use both together. I'll show you
some examples but um just really quick
verticality strength 1 through 10 one is
the lowest setting sort of the the
minimum required 10 is the strongest now
that's not meaning that only one of you
know I said there's like nine different
aspects of order flow that doesn't mean
that it's only one aspect and and 10
would be everything no it's it's a scale
sort of an intensity scale think of it
in in that term so one is the lowest
intensity 10 is the highest Um, sort of
the common levels that I use are, you
know, 1 3 5
7 and 10. And to be honest, there's
there's not much difference when you're
going from one to two or two to three,
but there's a bigger difference
obviously when you're going from one to
three or three to five. Okay.
Um, swing filter. Right now I have it
disabled. Uh, minimum volume required.
Obviously, you know, you want at least
some decent amount of volume. I found
that a minimum of 10 is good enough. We
could have hardcoded that in, but uh you
know, I did want to make it user
adjustable. Most markets 10 is is
plenty. Uh maybe if you know there's I I
know there are traders out there that
trade a lot thinner markets. What do I
mean by thinner markets? You know, some
of the uh agricultural products
um can be kind of thin at times and and
the the
you know, the the meats as well can be
thin. So maybe you want to move it down
to five, but um again that's up to you.
You could keep it at 10. 10 is fine for
pretty much 90% of the markets.
Momentum strength is set to six. Well,
in this example, I've set it at six,
okay? Cuz I want to show you guys sort
of the step down with the momentum
strength.
If you have it at zero, then you've
disabled it. The highest you can go is
six. So it's 1 2 3 4 5 six. The lowest
obviously when it's enabled the lowest
would be zero but when it's enabled one
would be sort of the minimum signs
momentum then it works its way up until
you get to six okay which is the
strongest momentum PC movement for now I
have turned off right there's a sound
alert so
this is this chart is e- minis yesterday
basically with just the minimum setting
of um verticality strength at one
and momentum strength set at six. Okay,
so you can see there's a lot of signals.
Okay, now when you come into
verticality strength of three, right?
Setting it a bit stronger still with
momentum strength, right? Because I like
to trade with uh momentum, you'll notice
now there are fewer signals, right? As
opposed to when it's set at one, right?
Obviously, one's going to give you the
most signals,
right? That's with verticality set at
three. Now, I sent out a chart
yesterday, I think, with verticality
strength at five, momentum strength at
six
in the E- Minis. It's a bit cleaner, but
at the same time, you you know, you're
still catching some big moves. you know,
I would have liked to catch this move up
that happened from about 10:15, which
you see, you know, there's no other
signals. So, there was just nothing in
the order flow that really gave you a
clue, right? That's just how it is.
Sometimes people say, "Well, I thought I
was supposed to catch these big moves."
Well, sometimes, you know, the order
flow just isn't cooperating in the sense
of giving you a signal.
Okay, so that's with five verticality
strength set to five, momentum set to
six. Now let's go up to seven. A little
bit stronger, right? And you'll see now
we don't have that initial move down. We
got something up here at near the high.
We start coming off. There's a sell, a
little buy. Um halfway down, you're
catching the uh the other cells down
there. So obviously, you know, you're
not catching some of these earlier
moves. And again, you know, the reason
why I'm showing you these different
things. Now, you know, a lot of times
people ask, you know, can you what
should I use for this? They'll say, what
should I use for E- Minis? Well, really
it it depends, right? On your chart
type, um, you know, are you using a
timebased chart? Are you using a volume
based chart, reversal chart, Reno chart?
um
you sort of got to figure out you know
because it charts are formed differently
and as a result of chart being formed
differently what that does to the order
flow is it formats it differently now
when I say formats I mean still the
order flow but it arranges it right cuz
if you're looking at you know sort of of
a wrinko chart it's putting the data in
different spots as it would on a normal
one minute chart or even a tickbased
chart right it it's calculated
differently Now here we're going to set
it at verticality strength at nine. I
mean I could have put it at 10 which is
the strongest but momentum strength at
uh six.
Where are we here? This one. So you can
see it's just like one 2 3 four signals
only right as opposed to when it was at
you know seven. You got a bit more or
that was five rather. This is seven.
But you see the difference between nine.
Right.
And one. Okay. So, obviously, you know,
if you're a scalper,
you know,
you just want to take some quick trades
in and out, in and out, over and over
and over. I'm not saying you got to take
every single trade, but I know traders
that have used some of my indicators
specifically, they set it as low as
possible
just to catch moves like this where
they'll add on, add on, add on, add on,
add on until,
you know, they they feel it's hit their
their profit targets. Okay, now
momentum set to zero. Okay, now
I'm keeping the verticality strength at
nine, the strongest momentum strength
set to zero.
So now it's not necessarily looking for
momentum. So as opposed to earlier,
right, when this was verticality
strength 9, momentum strength six at the
highest, right? This is what it looked
like. So you see there's just one, two,
three, four. One buy, a sell, another
sell, and a buy.
when we're at momentum strength of zero.
Okay, you've got the buy, sell, the
sell, the sell, the sell. Okay, now
scale it down strengthwise, still
keeping momentum strength at zero.
Okay, so now you're starting to see a
few more signals come in. Okay, go down
to five verticality strength. Still
momentum strength at zero. Again, you're
starting to see more people say,
should I use momentum strength? Should I
not? Well,
the reason we got swing filter and we
have a momentum filter, okay? Because,
you know, there's traders that like are
a bit more on swing trading, right? Sort
of capturing big moves. And so, you want
to be aware of where those trades are.
And there's others that like to trade
with momentum.
So
when you have right like here, right,
you got momentum strength zero. It's
going to pick in pick up the
swing trade that was here, right?
Remember when I showed you the
the chart from earlier? Let's go back
here. Um this one, five and six, right?
I said, "Ah, I wish there was something
that caught this move up here." Well,
it's because I have the momentum filter
on
and down here at this low
down here with the swing fil sorry with
momentum turned off. This one came in,
right? Because the reason why this
signal is not coming in when momentum is
turned on is because there's no bullish
momentum. It's coming in at a low.
Right. So, bullish momentum hasn't
started building up yet.
So, you know, I'm showing you these
these different charts, right? This is
verticality 5, momentum strength zero
that could help you catch maybe, you
know, some moves at swing highs or swing
lows. You know, again,
it's
to be honest to catch a move of
verticality at a swing low or a low of
the day um really has to be a strong
signal because generally speaking, you
know, sort of the best moves is right
after market's going a little bit
sideways and starts to run, right? Like
here, catch this nice move down just as
up here was sort of going sideways um
and then dropped out.
Okay, so that's five. Um, this is three
and zero. So, obviously, you're seeing a
lot more moves. And again, you know,
when momentum strength is turned off,
you're going to get a lot more signals
because it's just sort of picking up
everything,
which again, I I just want to show you
because
in my opinion, you know, I think the
default is is with momentum strength
turned off for verticality strength set
to one. Um, it's going to look like
this, right? just going to be like wild
signals every other not every other bar
but you know you don't want some of
these bars where it's just like really
gives a buy signal then stops you out
right that's why I like to use um
momentum strength just to you know help
give me
some sort of uh
clue so PLC movement filter just really
quick now
when When you start adding filters to an
indicator,
doesn't matter if it's just mine or any
other thing,
what it does is it obviously you're
filtering out something else. So, you
should when you're doing your analysis,
you're testing to find out what settings
work best in your market for verticality
or any other indicator. I I suggest you
start setting everything at at the
lowest amount and and work up from
there. Sometimes, you know,
people set levels at at such a high
level that it just doesn't really work
out because it's super strict. So,
verticality strength one, momentum
strength one, PLC movement one. Okay.
Does clean it up a bit, you know, but
still, you know, I'm not pleased with
that. All right. So, then you got to go
a little bit higher on strength momentum
one, PLC movement
one. Right. Looks nicer. Right? you're
starting to catch a lot of the major
moves without the noise sort of, you
know, there is a little bit of back and
forth in in here with the buy followed
by, you know, the sell followed by the
buy.
Okay, I can live with that. I can live
with these little stopouts here. If I'm
going to catch a move, you know, I can
get stopped out for four or five points
here. if I'm going to catch a move
that's, you know, 10 points or, you
know, close to 50 points here.
Okay, so that's verticality three,
momentum one, PC one.
Okay, now let's mix it up a little bit.
Let's make
PC movement a little bit stronger. We're
going to set it at three.
Okay,
so now it looks a lot better, right?
You'll see movement and catching this
nice move up, nice move down. It's got
rid of some of this little sideways
activity in here. I mean, there are
still a little poor trades here or here.
Okay, I I could live with little
stopouts. I mean, that's how it is as a
trader. There's going to be trades that
you times you do get stopped out,
but your winners obviously need to
recoup your losers, right? And you can
see you're getting the big winners,
right? That's the whole point of the
verticality indicator. Now, let's make
it stronger. Five. I don't think you
really need to go higher than five on PC
movement. I mean, you can, but um
I think five is is good enough.
Okay. And again, it's got rid of a few
of the poor trades because I think there
was a buy here at 130. And it's a lot
cleaner. Okay. So, again, you know, when
you're adding filters, you got to
realize what you're doing on how it uh
reduces some of the the amounts of
trades. Okay.
And that's with PLC movement at five.
Now, let's go back. PC movement back
down to zero. All right. It just shows
you, right? you see a lot, right? You
don't want every single signal, right?
That's that's how you got to start
ramping it up with the filters.
Okay, now momentum strength set to two.
All right, we still got verticality at
one, PLC movement at one.
Okay, and again, you know, that that
clears it up. So, you know, when you're
going through the charts,
right, what what you want to be doing
right now here's giving some sell
signals is is you want to find, you
know, what's ideal for you, right? Right
now, I got one and six here. Okay. If
you know, other other markets,
you know, this is
where are we here?
So, this is Ultra Bonds today, right?
The one that I had earlier was the day
before. I mean, then you're talking
these are these are big moves, right?
You can see it doesn't even come up here
and stop you out at the top of this
zone, right? Or even here. This is, you
know, at 1212 up here is 13. Your stops
up here at at 14.
Okay. From 120, you know, realistically
short from 12010. It trades all the way
down to where we are right now. Where
are we trading? 11924.
you know, and
when you're talking about markets,
you know, slower moving markets,
ultra bonds,
dude, probably don't even need I I have
momentum strength turned off, but you're
going to use the the lowest setting. You
could start there, right? This is the
default setting, okay? When when you
first add verticality on here,
right? It's one.
nothing else is turned on. Okay?
You know, and for some of these slower
moving markets, um, you know, ZB,
you know, every every market that you
look at, start with the default setting
and then you start sort of layering in
the momentum filter or the swing filter.
Okay? So, ZB obviously just that one
signal there.
You could even let me just show you here
some of the stuff you can do. Say, you
know, I like to look at rangebased
charts, you know, interest rates, not
time based. Problem with time based is
you don't get enough movement sometimes.
I'm just curious how it's going to look
here.
So, I'm basing my signals off of the
four range chart, right? So, obviously
it looks a lot better, right? You got a
lot of bearish signals coming in. I like
to use a four range chart
in interest rates, bonds, tens, fives,
[laughter]
ultras, because in my opinion that that
gives you enough information
and it puts the data in an easy to read
format and that's the beauty of it. So
now if I was just managing a trade on a
one minute chart, makes it a lot easier
for me to manage it. I can manage it
over time, but I've taken
the signals based off of the four range
chart and put it on here.
Okay. And if I wanted to, I could even
um highlight the signals using the swing
period, right? So, okay, I just want to
take the signals when they're coming in
at,
you know, um a high or a low. Okay?
So now I'm using swing as opposed to um
every signal or say I want to use u
momentum
right I could set it to sort of
three is sort of in the average in the
middle area.
All right. So, here I have the settings,
the signals when it's set with uh
momentum,
[laughter]
sorry,
sorry, drink something here. Um,
yeah. Uh, let's take a look at something
else. Uh, like eurourrency. Okay.
Like we had this nice sharp move down in
the Euro currency this morning where it
dropped from you know 11622 right here
all the way down to you know below 116
even right this is these are those moves
that you want right as a trader man if I
could just what was in the order flow
happening earlier.
Okay. So again, this is with, you know,
a setting of uh
one and [clears throat] three. Again,
you know, if I could I could have it at
zero, right? The default setting.
Whoops, that's a four range
chart. So, let's go back to chart. I can
put that back at zero cuz I'm looking at
a four range. So, this is on the
Let's move this stuff around here a bit
so it's a little easier to see. Put that
here.
get the settings here. Okay. So, again,
you know, I'm not I don't like this area
right before the big drop was out of
buys or sells. Um, and I know that's
just because I don't have anything
filtered out
right in here. It's it's just
verticality strength. There's no PC
movement, nothing in there, right?
Right? I mean, if I had PLC movement,
um, this is how PC how it looks with PLC
movement. So, it's catching obviously
that big bar down and that big sharp
drop. Um, if I were to use
momentum strength,
you know, three.
It doesn't obviously catch that one
because there's no momentum built right
from that high, but it catches it still
around the same level to catch most of
the move down.
Okay. Or you could even, you know, make
it stronger at at say six.
Okay. So, obviously, right, there's
nothing on no momentum. You got it right
up here at the top. Momentum of three.
Sort of came in a little bit lower in
here. Now with momentum set to six,
obviously it's coming in um a little bit
lower. Okay. So again, you know, you can
you can adjust that or you know, if you
want another thing you can try to do is
again if you're not going to use moment,
you know, maybe you're going to set
verticality strength higher five.
Again, it goes from 1 to 10, right? You
see it in here.
Maybe you want to use a little bit of
momentum strength.
Okay, a little bit different but kind of
similar.
Okay, so
when using filters like swing filter,
momentum, PC movement, start with the
lowest settings and work up.
Okay. Now,
question I get going to get I know is um
does it work with markers? Yes, it does.
It does work with markers. And I have
here sort of the the setups I could I
could take you through it. Um
cuz people always say, you have a
template for it. Okay. Well, I could
have a template for it, but at the same
time, settings that I use on the market
that I trade might not be the same. You
know, everyone trades different chart
types,
different uh
time frames, etc. But you know what? I
I'll just take you through it really
quick here,
right? It's very simple to set up. So
what you got to do is you go to once you
have markers right you just add it
then you got to use copy I like to use
copy okay so you're going to need
markers plus markers copy and copy one
for the buys one for the sells okay so
in here a couple things you're going to
need to do obviously you're going to
need to choose your account
your ATM that you're using Um,
then you're going to enable longs,
enable shorts, fast signals. Okay? And
you see when you enable fast signals, it
changes it from arrow up, arrow down
to this where it says go long, go short.
Um, I like to use the words actual
longs.
I mean you could have it whatever you
longs shorts or long or short or just
keep it at go long go short um enter on
market orders etc. I don't need to
change any of these things but then this
is where it gets a little trickier under
markers copy. So use as fast signal.
Yes. So you remember in here where I
changed longs
buys to long right. All you got to do is
you change this one where it says my
line one. Change that to long. Make sure
you spell it correctly.
Okay.
Then data series input series. This is
what it's going to base the buys off of.
So you go into your indicators, right?
And you find
um here, right? Verticality. Okay. Let's
make this bigger. Very small. Um
okay. whatever you're going to have it
set at, you know, on your underlying
chart, right? So, if I use the default
settings of one, you know, maybe I'm
using
five or something, you know, I would
change I'd have the same settings that I
have as the indicator on my chart. Okay,
so it's just one. I think I got momentum
strength set at one. Well, I can check
here. What do I got? So, whatever I'm
using here. So, so it's five and one.
Okay. Verticality strength five,
momentum strength one. So in here
uh verticality right
five
and one. Okay.
Then everything else is the same. This
is important down here where it says
parameters. Okay. Okay. So, this is my
buy. So, you have buy and sell. So, for
my buy, that's what I'm using for my
buy. Okay. So, okay, there. And again,
you could change this plot. You know, it
could be a dot. I I like to have it as a
blue for buys, obviously. I mean, you
can change it from dot to whatever you
want. Triangle up. It just will just
plot it on the chart for you.
Very important. Calculate on each tick.
Okay. As opposed to on bar close make it
on each tick. Okay. Then these that's
for the first one is for the buys,
right? Longs. Now this one is for the
shorts. So I'm going to change this to
shorts.
Okay. Use this fast signal.
Again, you got to change this to on each
tick. This is this is for cells, right?
I like red for cells. Um triangle down
this time. And again, don't forget in
here data series. This is important
because it's a little bit different this
time. Um,
verticality. So remember it was five and
one. But down here on the bottom, the
parameters, the default on markers is
set to buys. Here you got to make it
sell signal. Okay?
So make sure you change that to sell.
Okay? And that's it. All right.
So then you know once it's that off but
once you turn it on then it'll start uh
trading for you. But again I I go
through all those steps in here as well.
this presentation I'm going to attach to
the user guide
you know [snorts]
and you know the ATMs
just really quick getting back to
because you have to choose your your ATM
some of you you know maybe you don't
have any ATM set up um open up chart
trader
right and you can create your ATMs on
the side here so you can choose from you
know when it says the setting and
markers
You can choose it from up the menu up
there, but for markers here, you could
say I, you know, I'm using one of my
accounts.
Well, I don't have names for them, but I
just choose from up here, right? You
could choose whatever you set in here.
All right,
you click up there, right? But then it's
it's weird because it'll show up now
in markers in here, right? ATM1. So
whenever I click up there, whatever I've
chosen will show up in here.
And you know, within markers, there's
other things you could adjust. You know,
your daily P&L, profit, loss, etc. But
all that's explained
in here. Okay.
Um, [clears throat]
all right. I'm going to take a look at
some of these questions here.
Uh,
hang on a second here. I'm just getting
the questions opened up here.
Okay, so let me just get back on a chart
here.
Uh, [snorts] Morano asks, uh, is the 30
secondond chart the favorite for this?
Well,
I I wouldn't say it's a favorite. You
know, it you know, basically it comes
down to
how you want to trade. I mean, even if
you're on a one minute chart, right? I
can pull up signals
based off of 30 second chart. You
obviously it's going to be signals will
be, you know, faster coming in. Let's
just pull it up here. Right? You see in
here under multi time frame, I changed
it to 30 seconds.
Um,
so it's going to take a while cuz now
it's got a I got a lot of data up on
this chart. So, we'll take a take a
second or two. Um,
Ryan says, "My current indicators I use
got me in ES at 12:35.
the S. What's it say? Can read this one.
Um,
unwind. I like to see what this showed.
What time frame are you in, Ronald?
Um,
Ben asks, uh, could this be accomplished
with utilizing multiple toolbox
indicators where you create your own
orderful combinations? Um, no. Uh
it's
can't be to the best of my knowledge it
can't be recreated with uh the toolbox
simply because there's forms of analysis
that we have going on in here that are
not available on the toolbox. Um,
so it just it can't
Blood Hound from Shark Indicators.
Well, if it works with markers, people
tell me, you know, I I don't use Blood
Hound. Okay. I know some traders that
use Blood Hound and markers, and
basically they tell me anything that
works with markers should work with
Blood Hound. Um,
Jacob, uh, well, generally Jacob
to get the replays.
Usually we post them up on YouTube, but
they will also appear um you know, if if
you sign up for anything, it should show
up. So, this is why it takes longer,
right? Because you can see here, right?
One of the reasons why it takes longer
to show up initially on a 30- secondond
chart, it's because the the time frame
is different than the underlying chart
as well as um
is basically cutting every bar in half
and then it's got to think and plot it.
But again, this is with one and six,
verticality strength at one, momentum
strength set at six, 30 second signals
being plotted on there. For me, this is
too much. But you get a general idea of
which way the the trends, you know, are
forming. I would probably use
five. Verticality strength is five. Um,
a
ask does it need orderflow plus
subscription? No, it just it reads the
uh it just reads the order flow on the
back end. It doesn't need that doesn't
do any level two or anything like that.
Um
it just reads level one data but you
don't need a footprint chart for it.
Okay.
Is is the settings um applicable to all
instruments? No. I mean every market is
obviously going to be different. So you
know you're going to want to maybe you
know adjust your settings. Okay. So for
example crude oil, right? This is crude
oil um with a setting of
you know
just one.
Okay, this is the the default setting.
Okay, people say well you know I know
there's going to be naysayers. Well, it
didn't catch that move up right here.
Well, there unfortunately there was just
nothing in the order flow
cluing you in before that move right but
you know from 9 this morning
right from this low you know move here
some moves there. Um, you know, if
you're on
say gold well that's toolbox. Um,
this is gold, right? This is gold this
morning. Is it this morning? Yeah.
Let's make it bigger. Scrunch it up
here. Right. Gold
had the order flow to give you the
signals from these lows here. This is
using, right? So, it's catching this
move up, this move up. This is um
setting of what? Three. Three and three.
Verticality strength to three. Momentum
strength
set to three as well. Um, you know, if I
use PC movement, I know it will clean up
some of PC movement, even though it's a
momentum filter.
To me, it's like a clean up. It cleans
up some of the filters or some of the
signals in the sense that, you know, if
a market is sort of rangebound, it helps
to clean it up because I know there was
some signal in here, which I didn't
like, but PC movement will get you out
of those trades in there. Okay?
So you just focus on this straight move
up. This move up. Okay.
Um let's see here.
Okay, maybe good time to use a tool when
you attach charts so we can zoom several
times. Charts and not get pics. I'm not
sure I understand your question there.
Um, Jacob, uh, can I combine verticality
with toolbox? Well, you you can
you can't add it into the toolbox, per
se, because they're two separate things,
okay? But I mean, if you're using
markers and you have a
something you created with toolbox,
then you want to use it sort of I guess
you could do it together somehow with
with markers where you're sort of adding
it in. Um cuz I know with uh markers,
right, you could add some of this other
stuff in here to give you, you know,
sort of other setups, but that's
something I can't answer. you'd have to
ask Pablo um that question.
Uh
Thomas asks uh
can you also offer the markers plus
special price with PayPal? Um I I don't
have any more licenses, right? I had a
special deal with Pablo um a couple
weeks ago with with markers, but uh I
mean I know Black Friday is coming up. I
know Pablo's probably going to have a
big sale for for markers.
Uh
do we need have any other indicators
like No, you don't need a footprint
chart. You don't need any other tools.
um you just use
a regular bar chart, right?
The indicator is doing all the analysis
on the back end, right? What what you
see on I don't know if I got a footprint
chart here. Um
so over here, right? So all this
information that appears on the
footprint chart [clears throat]
is being read by
verticality on the back end, right? And
it's taking this information and then
it's plotting it, excuse me, on your
chart here to give you the buy signals
or the sell signals. Okay.
Um,
asked, "Can you share the settings on
strategic traders on RV bar types with
this indicator?" Yeah, I'm going to get
to that. Um, not on this presentation,
but I'm going to be posting stuff. Um, I
just wanted to get this presentation out
of the way.
[clears throat] Uh,
James ask, can talk about how to use the
triangles
and lines produced by the indicator.
Not sure how to interpret. Okay. So,
it's quite simple. So, all right. So,
you see these these red lines. Okay.
Then you see
the red triangle. Okay. The red line.
So, like up here, right? You got a blue
line, a blue line, right? But there's no
triangle. The triangle is where you get
in on, right? That that's telling you,
hey, you know what? We had a signal
appear, starting to appear. So, this red
line is going to be your stop level.
The triangle is your entry. This
triangle won't reprint after the bar
closes, right? And the area that you're
going to have your stop is behind this
red line. Now, for example, you have
this blue line with the triangle. Okay?
So, the blue line comes first, followed
by the triangle on the next bar. Okay?
When the triangle appears, that's your
sign to get long. Right here you have a
little blue line that was formed but no
triangle. So you're not getting long.
If there was the follow-through order
flow with using the trade because I have
the trade entry signal enabled. That's
why there's no trade signal. So the
triangle is your signal to get in or
out.
A non techchnical question. Um,
not sure I understand your question,
man. Art,
how do you set up the timebased
footprint chart that shows more bars
moving up and down and doesn't move the
screen so fast?
Well,
all you do is you change the the
setting, I guess. I mean, I'm not sure I
fully understand your question. They
saying um this is a nontechnical guy
time based footprint chart that shows
more bars moving up and down doesn't
move the screen so fast um
just really quick since we're on this
question just came up here um what you
can do I mean the only markets it really
applies for would be like NASDAQ or MNQ
you would aggregate your ticks tick
aggregation to four okay Um,
Ben says, "I see
CNS just had a bar with a signal in both
directions." Well, yeah. Where was that
chart here?
There was a bar here. I forgot. This bar
right down here at the bottom. This is
based on a 30 secondond chart. All
right. So it's the even though it's a
one minute chart on here, it's
so the the under the chart that you're
looking at is got it
is a one minute chart, but the actual
signals are based on a shorter time
frame. So there can be a rare instance
of a buy and sell signal coming in at
the same time. All right. I don't know
if there was any others
or not,
but it it's rare, but it can happen when
you're looking at different time frames,
you know, but you know, that that buy
signal did precede that nice move up.
Um,
guys, I don't know. I I know you guys
can hear me cuz I see a lot of questions
coming in. I know Steven said he
couldn't hear me.
Some stop levels are lines, some are
region. They're all lines. Um
Abby asks uh
the cost it's uh well here I I put the
link in the chat here. Okay, so
it's in here, right? So it's just
orderflows.com/verticality.
Okay. And right now, you just scroll
down. You could either go by PayPal or
by Stripe. Um, there's 2.89,
which isn't that much. You know, I know
there's a lot of indicators sell for a
lot more. They do a lot less.
You know, some questions. Do you need uh
level two? No. Do you need a footprint
chart? No. Is this a footprint chart?
No, it's not a footprint chart. Okay.
Um, how many PCs can I run the indicator
on? Well, it runs the the license is
linked to whatever your Ninja Trader
machine ID is. Okay? So, you can't run
it on two different PCs. So, when you
install it on one PC, cuz I know some
people like myself, you know, I've got a
bunch of PCs, each one requires its own
license. Um, like I have a laptop, so if
I go travel, I bring my laptop. So, I
can't if I have the license that I
entered on my desktop, I can't use it on
my laptop because they they have
different Ninja Trader machine IDs that
would require an additional um license
token. Okay.
So, anyway guys, um yeah, I mean if if
you got any questions, you could just uh
shoot me an email.
Um anyway guys, I'm going to thank you
guys for coming out. It's we've been
going on just about an hour now. Um like
I said, it's a great uh it's a great
tool. You can see, you know, using a
very short time frame to catch that nice
big sharp move up there. Um you know,
gold's been kind of acting where are we
now? 40 bucks or sorry, 4,000 bucks,
4075.
You know, euro.
Well, this is my euro that I got going
on here. This nice one. It's catching
some nice movies there. you know, it's a
great little tool. It's a very I think
should help a lot of people
find better trades. So,
you know, just really quick and also in
here, I had a couple this was I sent
this chart out yesterday, but I included
it in here with the settings. Um, I'm
going to all these slides I'm going to
attach in the user guide um as well.
you know, maybe I'll I'll send it out
when I I'm going to send the replay outs
because I know a lot of guys um you
know, some of you guys had to to leave
early or came in late. Um but I'll I'll
include the slide deck a link where you
can download the slide deck as well in
case you want to go through here and get
a better look at it some of the
settings. So again, you know, just go to
orderflows.comverticality.
Okay guys, so thanks again for coming
out and I'll see you guys later. Take
care.